you're just killing it with everything
that's happening in your life I have to
ask what has been your highlight this
year getting married to my wife has been
the highlight for sure having my whole
family friend and life network in one
place just sort of celebrating love that
was definitely a highlight yeah it was
so watching this film as well you really
are Superman like you're the real-life
super man you're fast with cars how
faster you drive that Bentley 180 miles
per hour
what is that in kilometers I think
that's like kickboxing champion you're
dancing with Taylor this movie was made
for you was there a highlight for you
that you can kind of lived your dream
out in this film
ah you know action heroes you know
always sort of sitting there sort of
zeitgeist of you know young young actors
yeah double Mel's we're all looking at
action heroes yeah whoever it's Bruce
Lee Chuck Norris or it was you know
rocky Rambo whatever and you know
Brixton has the characteristics oh and
the potential to be one of those sort of
characters that are you know sort of fit
that box I loved it I like fighting you
know like you like fighting but I like
bikes I like all that stuff so about to
play a character that lives that here's
a big ego way bigger than mine I got to
play that a little bit as well I loved
it you're so good in this film I have to
ask when you start your self as a CGI
cat clean shaven what was your reaction
look man I'm so like you know
moviemaking is incredible at the moment
they're like a magic we can do Tom
Hooper had this man envisioned for cats
to take it off the stage which is
incredible on the stage but to put it
into the cinema scope and I just like
I'm so proud to be a part of that you
know
I'm playing macavity which is like a
really poor is a poor guy who poverty
but he's a bit of an OE cat yeah yeah
but I'm excited for people to see it how
would you describe this film in one word
vie be good was good words